ma la corona che successo natura la
desidera
sono io si rintraccia l'angelo dove vi
invito
ad
[Risate]
oggi proveremo vari giochi poppy
playtime 3 è il continuo di pupi
playtime due se non avete visto un po
più per i tagli 2 abbiamo fatto tutto il
gioco si vedevano basta già iniziando a
spiegare perché 19100 qualcosa questa
porta c'è una tornata qualche parte il
lettore trova il codice per la porta ok
ok sbrighiamo sui e il codice in vaccino
porto le si trova a aiuto io mi sono già
perso
che bello giocare ma che si trovano le
cose imposto prima di noi ok perché
teletrasportato d'altra parte un nuovo
questo gioco si chiama statue ma come
probabilità in due il lombrico né
cagnolone ti ricordi che rendono tratto
dall altra parte è quello di fare il dj
fitch e il re il bjp capillare nome
strano che
proprio qui a fianco no no è meglio non
saltare gli intesta telo poi si arrabbia
di più
allora ok brano fermo fermo no aspetta
come era quando le luci a certi aspetti
locali mentre aspetta
[Musica]
il fermo di puoi solo girare per
controllare meglio la terraferma no
aspetta mi sto dimenticando dobbiamo
muoverci parole di aceto spente vista
che dovevamo muoverci con le luci
specificare d'alfredo allenamento addio
vitali addio perfetto
perché
ragazzi sono rientrata nel gioco va non
c'è io non ho fatto in tempo ad entrare
a vitale è stato preso da pj pack up
here ma noi vediamo se riusciamo da soli
a battere il gioco parità in italia ok
riproviamo ci spetta
un due tre stella molto più difficile io
poi qua non c'è neanche la musica almeno
un lato trovamo
sei sicuro che stia andando nella
direzione giusta ma non ho idea di dove
sto andando ottimo
pure che a tutta prima un patto cioè
contro generazioni capire l'altro lato e
tantino blacks
si è mancato il giochino è film o mens
lettera ok se abbiamo fatto a passare
dice che c'è dove mar l'ex lì lo vedi
eccolo del vino bluff mobil home l'ex
sede di long l'ex aderisca parti si fa
male dopo 21 gen etologi ne torna giusto
non girare intorno sapeva ma ma anche fa
mattina sia
in modo così bravo in posticcia i
pattini a rotelle ma sale anche sulle
piattaforme per fortuna e lenti pochi
secondi ancora riusciremo a sopravvivere
addetti non black bison trova il bottone
forse quasi qualcosa
no non mi fa passare
abbiamo trovato l'uscita di ariosto di
mattera bretta sì sì sì sì era quella
di evitare mi raccomando non si
sfracellare anche perché questi sono
quei giochi che davis prende per parlare
con i robot c'è pure il tempo più mi
fanno venire troppa matera ma ecco che è
capito o gennaio è caduto lui vero
per non andare di barche davis primi
minuti
il torino invece la mozione
[Musica]
contro
due
vediamo quest'altro gioco come
innanzitutto che bello vedere la
fabbrica da fuori anche perché sapete
poi la impossibilità in due non siamo
ricerca presenta quindi non abbiamo mai
vinto da furto r1 riguarda c'è un camion
rosso pippo sapere a guidarlo puoi
trovare ma secondo me non funziona
ok entriamo nella fabbrica perdiamo la
pratica allora centesimi lo blacks
vestito da pupazzo di neve
ciao ciao
[Musica]
allora diciamo qui qui c'entrano qui
incoraggiante rosso verde rosa giallo
danneggiamento del codice sì allora non
si veste rosa giallo perché travo allora
codice per ora lo posso inserire qui più
bello ci sono le scatole con i giochi
tipo gli ominidi rob lowe troppo care mi
hanno fatto un mix tra bubi playtime ero
block
stimato bambino blu ridiventato di
aiuto
e c'è un bottone dove
ho trovato al neon mahmud l'ex
nostro primo morto
se non avete visto l'altro episodio in
cui ci trasformiamo in babila black
edition blacks per continuare cosi e gli
altri devono trovare tutti morto
celestin da se vogliamo dopo questo
video truppe e troverà
anni allora
invece di antigua di che vuol dire che
dovremmo scappare da dei binomi l'ex
immagino allora qui forse c'è qualcosa
vediamo per chi non sa prendere qualcosa
avevo preso
ribadiva blacks
trasformarmi in king the deal o blacks è
carino
blacks dove sei
te che noi siamo fidanzati immagino è
però aspetta sono tutti i kings 4 dove
sei
e io dove il miur ngn tu dove sei solo
nel tunnel che porta al youm station
ecco cosa abbiamo subito il treno
sicuramente intoppi playtime 36
credo che uno dei personaggi più animati
o chiuso ma principali sarà the deal on
lega perciò potremmo
sicuramente tornerà a pochi visto com'è
finita
i due secondo voi scrivete nei commenti
hip hop e pulita in tre ci sarà il
personaggio principale che dovremo
affrontare perché nel primo il
personaggio principale era a chi quasi
esatto nel secondo era bambina blacks
nel 3 chi starà secondo me saranno i
pochi botte perché praticamente lei
avevo che è stato tutto con malonga
quindi secondo me sarà proprio lei
invece secondo te chi pensi sarà la
secondo me però un nuovo personaggio the
deal on black steel ombretti secondo voi
scrivete nei commenti mi sembra che lì
non c'era più niente quindi ne prenda la
corona che è successo al tour una
lettera
e un po confuso dell'amplesso se vai in
fondo al corridoio poi finisci tipo in
una sorta di magazzino della fabbrica
perché sapete che questa è la fabbrica
dei giocatori malefici di poppi playtime
ancora non ha trovato nelle latino però
io sono più avanti di anita
ne ha più vitale di mary pezzo di sì
posso vedere quanti ne ora ne sono due
io invece ne ho ben 4
ei ma insomma c'è niente qua cerchiamo
meglio
a questo nascosto e idee ma che fa
qualcosa fa sempre nella scatola non
riesca a prenderlo ma se io salgo su
sanità e può prendere qualcosa nella
casa l'amico vedete si sono riuscite a
salire vediamo che cos'è
ai ronde di robbie
keane lo proviamo subito un tipo di vino
un l'ex di fuoco con le ali di fuoco e
figo ma poi volare anche no purtroppo no
mi sarebbe piaciuto volare ma non posso
wow piceno un passaggio segreto nelle
tubature di voler o tipo come i pochi
playtime 1 quando ci insegue a chi vola
chi seguendo questo giocatore perchè non
fate questo andando io sto andando wow
che figo malati di vista quest'area day
time
no super colorata che è in atto
ovviamente nell'altra uscita ho trovato
un'altra film davvero un
impostore di among us bovara testi
contro la cosca sono una sala di
controllo
ho trovato un'altra quindi vede di
download con gli occhiali o segreto
[Musica]
tre agguati infuocato tipo cattivissimo
è sicuramente una skin anche quella tra
un giocatore io ho paura di prendere
acqua si è un giocatore non mi fa niente
un posto teletrasportarvi lo va bene
però vero che potevo dare trasportarmi
che beve anima di angelo teli se tu
questa lo riescono i conoscenti
no io sono melania in di share ok
vediamo oggi trovare anche all uomo
bianco angelo era troppo bella per la
spina vediamo se l'altro club è così
sicuramente questo non sapevo se
nascosto provarsi
[Musica]
sembra tipo il dada parti avete sentite
video che facciamo al parco giochi
andato parti ma un bellissimo video
montaggio allora li promossa dire qui su
queste su queste specie se in campo qua
è visto si è qui e lì dove ho trovato ai
luoghi di fuoco ehi ma io non trovo un
bel niente
le leggi ha rubato in tour e steam
potremmo su qualche cosa non ci credo
tutti io sono qui le norme sono state
sacco di tempo c'erano ottenuto nei club
prendi unicorn è preso vediamo come mi
voglio trasformare in unicorno solo
dell'ex unicorno perchè è brutta
sono qui sono qui sono stato trasformato
meno sono un ricordo ma eccomi aree c
confonderemo e si sono quindi il router
ok proviamo entrare quasi perché non
abbiamo speranze vediamoci costretto
attenzione area
insomma potevate spargeremo più rischi
mamma mamma ti dirò è il bar dove a kim
hwang in bianco era troppo bella quella
pin trovo niente aspetto ha trovato
qualcosa qui nel trend si alla fine del
39 di selezione edile blackstone e
galaxy tab il homeless lo voglio anch'io
dimmidove dov'è
allora tanto ti vedo che sei lì quindi
assicura rete si poteva offrirci tanto
qua devo provare subito questa sera
bisogno di un orecchio prima e vara
beli
[Applauso]
stupendo per cento il latte
allora prova a tornare in baker ok fondo
me c'è qualcosa che non abbiamo trovato
qua ma io voglio dirlo perché a volte
sono andato negli anni dico adesso ho
trovato amici del di rom l'ex dove mini
le vedete io la trovo poi aspetta
sono io sono un crepaccio l'angelo dove
deve subito a scappare
jimmy subito dove la fina gelo noi
romanisti che non ti ricordano che l'ho
presa bene in meno dai baby consegnavano
no vabbè troppo bene guardate
presentiamo le dell'altro è servita
umida d'italia non mi rivolgo dall'altra
davvero eric white a napoli ho trovato
mini guarda questo qui
[Musica]
dai dimmi dove lager e lo ricordo per
davvero
hai trovato superman sì ma come fai a
trovarne così tanto cercare meditare
guarda ecco che mi sono trasformato il
superman
certo c'è un po di pancetta questo super
ora cerchiamo meglio non è giusto che
vitale ritrovato tutti roma niente
allora vediamo cosa nel porto
beh io ho perso il mio prodotti
allora io ho preso come
12345678 che basta c'è scritto pure qui
88 ma vota vito vitale
però avete visto gli altri video vi
lasciamo ora qua quattro casi li esclude
i care per i nostri altri video il caso
quella che preferite buona visione ciao